hi there take a look at this humanoid
right here it walks from one checkpoint
to another checkpoint and then to the
next checkpoint and so on and that is
its task it gets a reward from walking
from checkpoint to checkpoint take a
look at this and this is called the end
it also walks from checkpoint to
checkpoint now we've seen a lot of
reinforcement learning algorithms in
this environment it's called MOOC MOOC
Ojo where you basically teach these
little things to walk around so the
what's the impressive part here the
impressive part is that at training time
this and has never ever seen what a
checkpoint is and has never gotten any
reward from walking from checkpoint to
another checkpoint actually it hasn't
ever gotten any reward for anything and
that that is given from the environment
it has discovered the skill of walking
by itself and then at test time there is
no additional learning when it goes from
checkpoint to checkpoint it simply
composes the skills that it knows from
it's unsupervised discovery phase in
order to go from checkpoint to
checkpoint so here you can see this
paper basically proposes to learn these
skills in an completely unsupervised way
at the beginning sort of so in the
training phase it learns these skills
you can see these skills that the
humanoid has learned and then all you
have to do at test time is to compose
these skills to reach a given goal and
these are the things that the end has
learned watch out this is trippy you can
see it has learned various walks various
ways of walking here and if you know
anything about this environment it's
actually not that easy
to make the ant walk by itself so the
the discovery here that these skills
that are discovered are various ways of
walking is actually already pretty
impressive and the last thing here this
cheetah of course also has to has
learned to walk back forward
cannot jump around and so on so we're
gonna dive into this paper it's called
dynamics aware unsupervised discovery of
skills by archie sharma and other people
of Google brain so this was published at
AI clear 20/20 and on a high level I
already said it's basically proposing to
learn unsupervised skills and then to
compose these skills in a model-based
planning method at test time to reach a
given goal without additional training
without additional training on the
reward that you give at test time as
always if you liked videos like this
you're very welcome to subscribe and
share it to everyone you know yeah okay
that's Ivan so they say conventionally
model-based reinforcement learning aims
to learn a global model for the dynamics
of the environment which is not exactly
true right so we have we dive into model
based and model free reinforcement
learning model-based reinforcement
learning basically means that you have a
model of the environment a example for
this is let's say tic-tac-toe
so in tic-tac-toe I know I have nine
actions at my disposal and if I take
action let's say I take action zero
which is to make a let's say I'm the ex
player so I take action zero and if you
know number my things correctly then
that will result in this state of the
world okay so I know exactly how the
world will look when I take a given
action and what that allows me to do is
that allows me to actually plan so I
cannot plan ahead I could say what would
happen if I took action zero so I can do
this in my mind and then what would
happen if I took action one I can be
like okay that's gonna happen and I can
do this with many things and I can in my
mind continue this and basically roll
out the entire games or and then
only do the given action that has led to
the best result at the end right so this
is model model-based reinforcement
learning means you have a model of the
environment you know what's going to
happen when you perform given actions
and you can also combine this with
machine learning like you know alpha
alphago alpha zero or so they have
models of the games they're playing they
know what's going to happen but it's
very interactive to basically go down
this entire tree and plan out everything
so they combined it with machine
learning
it doesn't change that it's a model
based now in in opposition to that in
model free in reinforcement learning
what you do you are this agent there's
the environment and you simply have to
do an action I do action zero and the
environment just gives you back a reward
and the next observation and it you have
basically no clue how the environment
will change if you do something you all
these and all these these agents do or
the classic model free agents do is
basically they're trying to have a
neural network somewhere in them and you
put the observation in here and outcomes
in action and you can do this in various
ways into Q learning or policy gradient
or actor critic and so on but ultimately
it's simply mapping the optic current
observation and maybe the last view to
the best action to take without
explicitly modeling what happens in the
environment now when they say
model-based reinforcement learning what
they mean is technically what you can do
if you're in if you are in the model
free and if you're in this situation
what you could do is you could say well
since these model-based RL techniques
tend to work better I could here inside
the agent I could try to learn a model
of the environment EEP rhyme and I could
try to basically learn what happens in
my environment when I do a certain
action and then I could use that model
right
here in order to do this planning that I
know from up here okay so in in this
case they go for exactly this they go
for let's learn a model of the
environment this is not an exact model
it's a learned model and then let's use
that to plan now this usually has a
bunch of you know very a bunch of things
that go against it namely if this model
right here is bad then the planning in
the model will often accumulate and even
exaggerate the errors that are in this
model so it's sometimes very hard to
learn a model of the world and then use
that for planning and I've recently
known a paper where we're curious AI
takes denoising auto-encoders to
regularize exactly such a planning
procedure to counter this this paper
right here is a different approach of
combining this learned model this
learned model so okay that was about the
first sentence they say it aims to learn
a global model for the dynamics of the
environment a good model can potentially
enable planning algorithms to generate a
large variety of behaviors and solve
diverse tasks which is true right if I
have a model of the environment then I
could just use it to plan I wouldn't
even have to do anything fancy anymore
right if I have a model of how my Tic
Tac Toe works I can just plan plan my
way to success and I can do this off a
zero style or if the this state tree is
small enough I can actually just use a
planner and I don't even have to I don't
have to do anything anymore if I have a
good model they say however learning an
accurate model for complex dynamical
systems is difficult and even then the
model might not generalize well outside
the distribution of states on which it
was trained so this is another problem
if you learn a model it's only going to
be valid in a certain range okay and say
in this work we combined
model-based learning with model free
learning of print and the model free
learning is of primitives that make
model based planning easy and so what
they attempt to do is they attempt in an
unsupervised fashion to learn so called
set of skills and the set of skills
could be something like walk forward
walk backward stay put
jump so they attempt to learn things
like this in an model free way that the
model is simply asked to come up with
these things or the agent is simply
asked tasks to come up with these things
and then in in stage two a planner can
use these skills and decompose a plan
now this plan here the special thing
about this plan this planner it doesn't
operate in the space of actions of like
small-scale actions it actually operates
in the space of these skills right here
so here would be walk forward walk back
so and with if we have a good enough
model of the environment it will tell us
if I walk forward in this situation what
will happen okay so I can walk forward
and then after that I could walk
backward what's going to happen and if I
have a good model of the environment
over the and the actions now are these
macro actions of these skills then I can
use planning to reach my goal okay so
the question is how do we come up with
useful skills that the planner can then
use so they need to be somewhat diverse
right but also and here is the the
crucial part and the the sort of
contribution of this paper they say how
can we discover skills whose outcomes
are easy to predict and this is how they
counteract this notion here that if your
environment model is crap then your your
it can't basically can't be used for
planning you'll just make it worse so
what they say is that these things right
here these skills that we learn we will
learn them in a way that make them easy
to predict so it make it makes it easy
to predict what will happen after I do
them so there must be at the same time
diverse so only you know if you stay put
it's pretty easy to predict to what's
gonna happen like nothing okay but we're
gonna see in the exact objective that
they have to be sort of diverse but also
so only one of them can be stay put the
other ones have to do something else but
also they should be easily predictable
by the environment model and if you
learn the skills such that they're
easily predictable your environment
model will make less errors and then you
can use it for planning okay let's dive
in they do actually open source code and
they have more of these videos if you
want to check it out I'll link
everything in the description ok let's
actually dive into the the meet right
here they say they do maximize the
mutual information and we're going to
see between between what and what
they want to maximize the mutual
information if you don't know what the
mutual information is the mutual
information is a quantity the mutual
information between x and y is a
quantity that's the entropy of X minus
the entropy of X conditioned on Y or you
can also be compose it in the other way
around entropy of Y minus entropy of Y
conditioned on X and we're going to they
apply this where is it equation 2 right
here okay so what they want is the
following they want to maximize the
mutual information and the mutual
information basically means how much
does one variable tell me about the
other variable ok
the mutual information between the skill
and we're going to see what that is and
the next state so what what is a skill a
skill is one entry in our table right
here so these here are skills skills and
they're in their index by Z now Z here
it seems like they're discrete right but
in this case they would be Z would be a
continuous vector but it's easier if you
imagine that so each one of this is like
Z 1 Z 2 and so on they're going to be
continuous but in our case we'll just
think of a discrete set of skills to be
learned okay
so they say we want to maximize the
mutual information between the skill
that's currently in action so and in
every at every time the agent has to
like choose a skill and saying like ok
now I'm going to walk forward and it's
in a given state and what you want to
say is you have to maximize the mutual
information between the skill and the
next state which means that it means two
things which you can see right here you
can decompose it in two different ways
one way is the following is to say if I
know which state I'm in what's the
entropy over my okay that's the wrong
bad way of formulating it it's if I knew
if I know these two things so if I know
the state I'm in and the next state that
I'm going to write I can in hindsight I
look back if I know both things what can
I say about this skill Z right here that
I couldn't say just from the starting
state so the starting state let's say is
the person right here and the end State
is the person a little bit more over
there so that's it's called this forward
it's the person is looking to the right
okay now if I only show you if I only
show you this state on the left the
starting state what can you tell me
which action is going to follow right
here basically you can't tell me much it
could be any action like support forward
walk back stay put but if I also show
you the next state then you can pretty
confidently say ah I know what you did
you did walk forward okay so this this
in this situation we would have a high
mutual information between Z and s Prime
in the formulation here if you decompose
it in the other way if this is
equivalent but it's a different way of
thinking about it it means when I show
you these two things how much more can
you tell me about the next state than if
I only show you this so in this
formulation what we would do is I would
say I tell you the human is here looking
to the right what can you tell me about
the next state and you look like what I
I couldn't tell you very much
right it can could be anything but if I
then tell you the action is
walk forward then you could say ah now I
now again it's probably going to be
something like this okay this also would
be a high mutual information so you see
that the the task of maximizing this
mutual information is good because what
happens if I don't if I have a low
mutual information if I have a low
mutual information it would mean that I
could predict the next state just as
well from the current state it doesn't
make a difference whether you give me
the skill or not it would not make a
difference and that is only the case if
my skills are basically either all the
same or all pretty pretty random and
pretty useless right so if if all my
skills are basically walking back
then I don't you don't have to tell me
which skill you do I'm gonna know that
the next state is like this so you can
see that the objective of maximizing the
mutual information between the skill and
the next state is going to result in a
situation where these skills are going
to be first of all diverse and second of
all easy to easy to predict okay and it
to see this yeah we only have to imagine
what would happen what would happen in a
in a situation where the skills weren't
diverse or weren't easy to predict and
you'll get exactly the situation where
the information of the skill doesn't
help you in predicting the next state
because yeah either it's obvious or it's
random okay so we agree that it makes
sense to maximize the mutual information
when they decompose this into two
objectives so they say the mutual
information thing is basically what
you'll have to do is you'll have to it
decomposes into two terms where you can
into two terms in a lower bound in the
mutual information and this is kind of
the this is sort of the standard
variational approximation literature if
you're into that read up on variational
autoencoders and things like this
basically the two steps here are you
tighten the variational lower bound and
you maximize the approximate lower bound
okay so you have the mutual information
and you can lower bound it okay you can
you can lower bound it by this quantity
now the if since this is a lower bound
you can prove that this is a lower bound
it means that the higher you make this
term then the the more basically okay if
it's a lower I don't know how to
formulate but it should be fairly
obvious if this if this thing on the
right is a lower bound to
the mutual information then maximizing
the thing on the right will maximize the
thing on the left and it will do so
very so imagine I is up here and this e
on the right side is down here it's a
lower bound right it's lower than I so
if I maximize e well I haven't really
done anything to I but if I maximize it
even more up to here and since it's a
lower bound I know now my I must be at
least higher than this okay so
maximizing a lower bound to quantity
will ultimately increase the quantity
but you can also the efficiency by which
it does this depends on how tight the
boundless so if the bound is very tight
like this you see I is not much above e
if the bound is very tight then
maximizing e will result in a faster
maximization of I okay so you can do two
things you can maximize the quantity
that is the lower bound or you can
tighten the bound and here you can see
that the difference that the tightness
of the bound depends on this quantity
right here which is the KL divergence
between this and this
so yeah let's watch this in the context
of we can actually go go through it on
the high level if you've never done this
variational approximation sort of math
then this might be a bit informative
okay so the thing right here is just
pops out of the definition of the mutual
information it's the it's basically the
differences of the entropies which the
entropy czar log quantities right so if
you have a log a minus log B that you
can also write this as the log of the
fraction of a over B that's just a
property of the log and so it's
expectations over logs these entropies
so you can write it as this thing right
here okay and this basically says this
is very high
or very low depending so you need to
weather or something is lower high
always will depend on what you exactly
you have to consider but ultimately what
you'll want is the ratio between this
quantity which is the probability of the
next state given the current state and
the skill you're taking divided by just
the probability over the next state
given the the current state in
expectation over all the skills current
state and next States now what they're
saying is this here this is basically
the environment right this is if you are
in a state and you perform a skill
what's the next state that's that's the
true environment here is the true
environment which we don't know we don't
know what the environments going to do
but we would like to learn a model for
the environment and this model for the
environment is now q q theta phi theta
phi greek-letter
so q phi here is going to be a neural
network that will approximate the
environment and in this probabilistic
framework it is going to be a learned
distribution that will approximate the
distribution of P all right so we
approximated by this but now this is
here it says equal equal right this is
not equal because this is just an
approximation so the equality must
become must be basically compensated for
by this term right here you can see this
here is expanded into these two you can
go through the exact definitions and see
why this is an equality but basically
you can say that the mutual information
is this expectation or it is this
expectation but now you have to correct
for the fact that here you only have an
approximation and you have to correct
for the
by exactly the amount by which the
approximation is different than the
quantity that you're approximating this
is this key KL divergence right here so
the KL divergence basically measures how
different two distributions are it's um
it's sort of a distance not exactly
distance but sort of a distance between
these two distributions right here it
says here's the real world and here is
your estimate of the real world how much
do they disagree and that quantity plus
then you can replace your world the
exact world distribution by your
approximate distribution and you still
are equal to the mutual information and
now the basically that trick is you say
oh the KL divergence is always positive
it's a quantity that it can only be a
positive number so if I leave it away
certainly this is own this is going to
be a lower bound to the quantity okay
all right so two tasks right here first
of all tighten the variational bound
which means make this quantity small
make your approximate world model as
close as possible to the real world how
do we do this neural network okay you
input trajectories I was in this state I
performed this skill and I ended up in
this state
sorry that's this and then you simply
match your neural network simply matches
what happens in the real world it learns
the transition function basically so
that's that's the tightening of the
variational amount and the second step
is this right here to to maximize the
approximate lower bound right the first
step was tighten variational a brand
that basically means make your world
model more accurate and the second is
tighten that maximize the approximate
lower bound now this is going to part
the this is going to be the part that
says now given that I already have a a
better world model right here
I improved my can I sort of improve my
skills such that they become easier to
predict and more diverse can I improve
my skills such that this mutual
information right here gets to be high
as high as possible okay
so this is sort of an alternating thing
and you can see this in this very very
very very confusing diagram honestly so
what are you gonna do in this algorithm
first of all in each episode you're
going to select a skill at random and as
I said these skills they're not
predefined so no one tells the agent to
walk for which it simply says okay you
have like in a discrete case you would
have like you have five skill slots
right and the only thing I require is
that they're sort of you know consistent
over time so skill one is always going
to be sort of the same thing and skill 2
but agent you can basically decide what
skill Awan is right but make the skills
such that it's predictable and that the
different skills are diverse okay so
you're going to sample one of the skills
like skill zero or what not and then
you're going to do two things first of
all you're going to learn these skill
dynamics which is you're going to learn
your approximate model of the world okay
and how do you do that basically here
you're the agent and the agent will so
what what does the agent have to do the
agent will take in the skill Z and it
will take in the current state of the
world and it will output an action now
this is the model free part right so the
agent that somehow has to come up with
saying our skills zero that's that's um
that's a walking forward and in this
situation walking forward means I have
to lift my leg or something like this so
you're going to take your skill you're
going to with your agent perform an
action based on that scale
the current state of the world then the
environment is going to give you the
next state right here and from those
things you can now learn your world
model you know I was in state s I I
performed action a but I performed
action a based on skills II and then I
ended up in state s prime and I can
learn a model of the world right this is
a trip like in to supervised learning of
a world model now here they do
probabilistic learning but and we're
gonna see in a second how that works but
ultimately they approximate the world
with their model cool so that's the this
outer loop and then what are they gonna
do next they're going to use that world
model to determine a reward for the
agent and the reward for the agent for
taking the action so the reward is going
to be our agent you took action eh now
what's your reward for doing this this
is the model free reinforcement learning
part your reward is going to be very
high if if this was very predictable and
if it is also diverse right so now the
agent has to sort of max sort of the
agent has to go and make this quantity
very high this we want the outcome of
these actions to be predictable and dive
and the actions themselves to be diverse
it is I'm sorry it's very hard to keep
all of this very straight okay but
ultimately two steps learn world model
from the experience that you've
generated and second thing learn the
agent such that it maximizes this this
quantity that we've seen before and you
do this via giving the agent a reward
that is proportional to the mutual
information and we've already seen that
we can approximate the mutual
information by
by this quantity here okay so learn
world model and make the agent go higher
mutual information two steps okay learn
world model is very very classic you can
say okay I need to improve I need to
minimize this KL divergence so I need
the gradient with respect to the
parameters of my world model I can write
down the KL divergence like this and
then since again I can do this reverse
so log a over B is log a minus log B and
since the world doesn't depend on the
parameters of my model this will simply
give me this thing right here which is
the gradient of the log probability
basically of my neural network and this
can be just optimized straightforward
this is a neural network optimize it
with gradient descent these are the
inputs this is the output now okay you
this is all probability distributions
but ultimately you can you can do it
pretty straightforward okay so
corresponds to maximizing the likelihood
of the samples from P under Q now the
second step maximize the approximate
lower bound okay so after they say after
fitting Q after improving our world
model we can optimize pi pi is the agent
that actually takes the actions based on
the skill so it's given a skill and it
needs to perform an action and it needs
to maximize this quantity as we've seen
needs to maximize the mutual information
between if I know the action and if I
don't or the mutual information between
the skill and the next state I say note
this is a reinforcement learning style
optimization with a reward function of
this quantity however so you look at the
quantity that they need right here the
quantity is going to be
this thing and this thing is just I feed
this skill and the state into my world
model and I look what what comes out of
the world model so this is I can compute
right but this thing right here I can't
compute because this is this is what
happens in the world when I'm in state s
and I just run my agent over in
expectation over all the skills so this
I don't know they have a log of this is
intractable and they so we approximate
the reward function for pi as this thing
right here now first let's look at what
this thing is so the reward of taking
action a and action a is based on skill
Z right
so skill Z was fed into the agent the
agent comes up with action AZ
oh you want me to walk forward in this
situation okay I'm gonna lift my leg
that's the action okay so the reward for
this action given this skill and given
the current state is going to be what
it's going to be very high if this here
is very high so it's going to be very
high if the probability so this s prime
is the state you ended up in right so
after taking the action you ended up in
s prime so if what what does it mean
when this quantity is very high it means
that my world model Q that is
approximating the world thinks that this
state is very probable if you were in
this state and are given the skill Z so
this basically means that the neural
network can predict with very high
accuracy what's going to happen if you
are in this state and are given this
skill to perform right this is one of
the things that we want now what is it /
it's divided by this and you can see
here the Zi are
other skills so it is what does this
mean this is almost the same quantity it
means how well can the same neural
network predict the next state if you
were given a different skill so it means
if I'm here and I ended up here how well
can you predict it if I tell you that I
walked forward and here you ask well how
well can you predict it if fails if I
told you you walked backward if I told
you you you jumped if I told you and so
on so you basically aggregate over all
the other over all the other skills you
could perform and each time you ask the
neural network well how likely is it
that you end up in the state that I
ended up in so what does it mean if this
quantity is high or sorry if the entire
sum here is high that means that the the
skill doesn't really give you much
information the neural network is very
good no matter which skill you selected
right it's it's very accurate in
predicting the next state doesn't really
matter the skill doesn't really matter
and this is what we don't want right we
want that the the the skills are very
diverse right so the top part is there
easy it's easy to predict what will
happen if you perform a given skill and
if we divide this by the bottom part and
this makes it such that these skills are
very diverse because if they're not
diverse then it doesn't really matter
which one you perform and then this
quantity on the bottom will be very high
but we divide by it so we want we want
it to be low okay now the reward is
going to be the log of this fraction
here and this makes sense right
intuitively but they're going to try to
motivate this mathematically and for
motivating this mathematically of course
they need to approximate this quantity
right here this quantity is the
denominator so they this denominator is
a prop is an approximation to the
it's an approximation as you can see
here this is sort of sort of a sample
based approximation to the transition
from s to s Prime under the distribution
of Z but what you want is just is the
transition from s to s Prime not in your
approximation but in the real world and
they formulate this they say okay we can
decompose it as such as a as an integral
over this conditional right here so they
bring in the Z variable and then they
say well this this is approximately
approximately we can replace this here
by this and we can replace this here
by this and say well since this is a an
approximation the to this is the world
model is an approximation to the real
world we can sort of replace that and
then this is the this is the part that
doesn't convince me they say well this P
Z of s we can just replace it by P Z now
this is it's very tricky to see what
these quantities are ultimately it ends
up being that right here but it's it's
it's so tricky so they could they say we
replace P Z given s by P of Z and okay
let's think about this for a second what
does the top the bottom quantity is
simply the distribution over your skills
and depending on your sample them this
could be like a uniform distribution
over your skills like that's fine but
what's the top thing the top thing
basically we can use base formula to
reformulate it it's P of s given Z times
P of
right times P of Z divided by P of s so
this quantity depends on multiple things
here is that prior again and this means
what's the general distribution of
states what's the general distribution
of states if your agent acts in the
world right this and this we don't know
we don't we don't know
and also this right here what's the
distribution in the true world what's
the probability of a state given a given
given that you were acting under a skill
Z and this is also something we don't
know because we don't know the world we
we don't have the world model so you run
into the same problem again and again
that you're trying to approximate this
and they want to make this so
mathematically rigorous but ultimately
and they go in the appendix they go
through various ways that they could
solve this but ultimately they just say
well this is approximately the same so
this right here it basically means what
skills if you if you're in a certain
State what skills brought to you here
basically what what skills brought you
here what's the distribution of skills
that brought you to this state and they
say well we're just gonna approximate
that by the prior distribution over our
skills basically disregard the state
here and this seems overly shaky like as
I said the entire paper makes sense but
I just feel it's trying to be overly
mathematical and then run into a point
where you can't be and then they're just
okay we'll we'll just replace it and and
then sort of things break down like you
can only be overly mathematical to some
degree it doesn't really fit but okay so
this is how you discover the skills you
maximize these quantities alternately
you learn the world model
and you improve your your skills by
making them diverse and easily
predictable so how do you then plan
using these skills this is the second
part of the paper and this is just as
complicated as the first part so they
say given the learned skills
so the learned skills are policies over
action given the DeeZee right now you
know how to like walk forward and walk
back and so on and now you're you are
placed in a world and you've given this
checkpoint it says well walk there and
you want this to do this using planning
you don't want to learn anymore you
simply want to plan okay what do you do
and as I said this is even more so what
you want to do is you want to do
something like model predictive control
but not over actions but over your
learned skills so you have this planner
in the NPC and the planner will in its
head roll out a number of different a
number of different plans it will kind
of explore a bunch of different
different plans z it will roll them out
and say okay if I do this and this and
this and this what will happen
using its world model that it has
learned it will observe what's going to
be the reward in each of these cases now
they say here access the environment
reward but can also be estimated and
this is another sort of I feel weak
point of this in that they now assume
they have the true reward function but
they don't have a world model right they
don't have the world model but they
assume that they can sort of always ask
for the true reward which is probably
not the case if you if you like if you
had a true world but it could be the
case the reward could be something like
well if you're over there you get higher
reward but you don't exactly know how to
get over there
in any case so they roll out a bunch of
trajectories in their head they kind of
plan forward see what's going to happen
if they do this or that or this or that
and then they choose the best one of
these forward thoughts and they execute
it in the real world right so they say
well I'm going to you choose the skill
walk forward
so the agent is now going to be tasked
with walking forward and it's going to
do that in the real world for a certain
amount of steps like ten steps of
walking forward after ten steps of
walking forward you go back you say I'm
in this new situation right here what
should I do
and again the planner is going to be
like ah if you first walk forward and
then walk back where are you gonna be
and so on
so the planner will always plan
basically to go from where you are to
the checkpoint using a composition of
the skills that you have learned so the
planner may be find okay if I first walk
forward walk back a bit and so on I'm
gonna get to the goal I'm going to reach
the goal now please agent execute this
first thing walk forward the agent
execute sit and maybe on you know it
won't do as well it will maybe end up
here and then it says well I'm here now
please plan again so it plans again it's
okay I can still kind of walk back I'll
be here here but then I have to do
something else
so now walk back and okay so this is
what's going to happen but it is going
to happen in a weird way namely what we
keep or normal since everything is
continuous we'll keep normal
distributions of all our future steps so
we don't say okay I go here and then I
go here what you'll say is i approximate
LIGO here and after that I'll
approximately go here and you'll do it
in such a way that the peak of this
normal distribution is going to be the
highest where you think you'll get the
most reward if you follow this
trajectory like if you follow this
trajectory of the very high reward and
if I follow at reject
that maybe goes here I won't get a
higher reward if it actually turns out
in your imagination that you do get a
higher reward for this trajectory you'll
change this distribution such that the
peak is here and of course the tighter
the peak is the more sure you are so you
sort of are looking if you look out into
the world you want the closest steps to
be very peaky and then as you look out
they can be more more sort of broad and
that's how you plan ahead you keep your
fun you keep doing a step so if you go
from here to finally you choose I want
to go here where the tip is the highest
oh here then you imagine forward again
you refine these distributions over the
future and then you take the next step
that gets you to that where the highest
peak is right here basically and so on
this is simply planning in a continuous
domain it is pretty analogous to how you
would plan in like alphago if you or
tic-tac-toe if you had a planner but
since everything's continuous it makes
it just so much harder so they yeah they
always update these distributions as you
can see here to the skill that gave you
a high reward in your imagination
compared to the rewards of the other
plans that you had okay well this was a
long long way until we got here but if
you recap so first they in an
unsupervised fashion learn these
low-level skills such that they're
easily predictable by their own world
model and diverse and then in the second
step they can use that to to do
basically planning so they first learn
these skills and then the planner
composes them to make the agent do
something and again the agent will never
have to learn how to do this go from
checkpoint to checkpoint because the
planner can just compose these low-level
skills
so they have these experiments right
here and we won't go through the
experiment because this video is already
very very long but they basically show
that they their learned things actually
their learned skills do end up being
very diverse do end up predictable have
a a high variance and so on they have to
give certain priors to it to make it
actually work
in a real setting but the results you
can actually see in these videos and in
the graphs I'm about to do check out the
paper if you're still here thanks for
being here I hope this this work was one
of the most more complicated and mathy
papers we looked at but I think I still
think it's fun and I still think the
outcome is pretty impressive right here
how you can use math to derive basically
these intuitive very intuitive
objectives to learn it's also pretty
cool all right that was it for me and
bye bye